[Applause]
my goodness
goodness gracious god bless you
i'm just a tad bit uh nervous because
i'm
wondering uh when i walked out here do
you uh think to yourself
uh whoo that's that's that's that's
that's a big dude that's that's a that's
a fat dude
i mean i'm i'm uh i'm floating i mean
naked
i'm fat but but when when when i got on
clothes
i mean i know how to you know i know how
to stand
so nobody really uh can wait a minute
wait my hair is uh wait all right here
here's my i'm not fat stand right here
[Music]
wait a minute wait a minute make sure uh
that's it right there make sure my chin
is not poked out
because i don't want to double chin and
also here's when you're legally fat is
when you get a stomach
and uh you know underneath your stomach
you get like an ass
in the front uh you're not supposed to
be able to turn your drawers backwards
and they uh
they fit better
i oh my goodness oh man
i'm see this thing i'm i'm nervous but
i'm trying to be cool because
uh that's the rules in the ghetto uh
i wish it was a holiday just once where
uh just you know black people don't have
to be cool
it uh you know it takes a lot out of me
i gotta be cool all you know
all the time i
can't smile ever you ever see a black
man giggle just
you get robbed you can't giggle in the
ghetto
i gotta pretend i'm cool all the time i
can't you know what i mean i'm a beatles
fan
i'm a closet beatles fan i don't listen
to the beatles tapes i listen to beatles
stays in the corner
like cause i can't be cool you know i
can't be a gangster
you know driving through harlem trying
we
all live in a year
[Applause]
hey yo hey dude you owe me some yo
look let me tell you something i gotta
have my money in two days boy
you got two days
oh yeah i tell you something
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man you know what in stretch two man
uh it doesn't sound like stress but you
know women
uh keep you keep your booties nice cause
uh
you know guys you know what i mean we
become good friends when we because you
can't enjoy a
you know nice booty by yourself you'll
see a nice booty alone you're looking
you start looking for something
you need a witness you know if i stand
next to her you know what i mean if i
was standing next to a klan member and a
woman walked by i'd say
hey hey man
oh man take off the hood so you can see
[Applause]
white guy's got a signal for nice uh a
nice booty and it's subtle it doesn't
involve like verbal content you don't
really have to talk
you just you know if i'm standing next
to the bus stop because you know where a
white guy signal for nice booty and a
woman walk by
don't confuse that don't confuse that
with nice chests that's different you
know nice chances
yeah uh black men uh brother black men
turned into ventriloquists we see a nice
ass who like
damn
[Applause]
i get this too a lot of times i get like
uh like you know
like fat people i don't know like uh
you know fat strangers they'll they
speak to me in the middle of the street
like we got some sort of
you know bond or something like you know
hey you know
hey i eat too i don't know you
get extra happy like you know you know
like like i do comments like
oh we have a voice oh my goodness
oh man hey big man represent man
represent
uh yeah i uh represent uh what you know
you know fat people when when i become
the leader of fat people i don't want to
lead fat people
nowhere what are we gonna do march the
the million pound march we're gonna walk
and sleep you know like a malcolm xxl or
something like you know that
hey thank you very much thank you i
appreciate thank you thank you thank you
that was great thank you so much patrice
o'neil everybody